servus die wir haben wir fragen an die
haftbefehle deutscher rap ist damals
schon richtig blamage dein raps
vierbeiners porsche erste frage was oder
wen findest du am deutschen bleibt
blamage
meine frage hätte ich werde es mit der
musikkarriere nicht so klappt wie du es
dir gewünscht hast würdest du dann
wieder so normal arbeiten oder wirst
wieder bei null anfangen und
irgendwelche drogen auf der straße
vertreten ist
da kommt noch eine runde kommen die
dritte frage be oder pac danke fürs
beantworten und sehr wohl
ich habe da mal vorbei da wo ja projekte
müssten nur die adresse beim nächsten
mal durch gegeben wenn ihr über klickst
du klickst du werde ich wieder bei clips
und bin könnt ihr gerne mal die adresse
gekommen dann abhängen trinkt man bis
dahin erhöhte da wo ihr abhängt
abgehackt was weiß ich auf jeden fall
erste frage war wer so blamage ist viel
simpler sind web sind meistens die
gangster importieren auf gangster machen
und dabei einfach nur lächerliche deppen
sind zweite frage war weiß ich nicht
dritte für arbeit arbeit ob du normal
auch so wieder oder war zweite frage ob
ich noch mal arbeit würde ich niemals in
meinem leben arbeiten weil ich kein
abschluss gehabt und ich geh nicht für
800 euro arbeiten die macht über in der
stunde und
dritte frage war
die park- oder boogie woogie alter an
leute gesagt wie new york es kursgewinne